EA is giving away free downloadable
content on battlefield 4 and battlefield
hardline across PlayStation Xbox and PC
this coming as part of their road to
battlefield promotion a new battlefield
is coming later this year and we're
celebrating by keeping the action going
in battlefield 4 and battlefield
hardline ta explain over the next few
months we'll be giving away previously
released expansion packs for both games
on anyone playing on xbox one xbox 360
origin for pc playstation 4 and
PlayStation 3 battlefield 4's dragon
teeth expansion is the first to be
offered and will be downloadable at no
cost until May tenth is available on
playstation 3 playstation 4 pc xbox 360
and xbox one EA will reveal a new
battlefield on may sixth developer dice
will be live-streaming a first look at
the future of battlefield on that twitch
page get inside the minds of the
developers as you hear from creative
director Lars Gustafson and lead
producer alexander grande I'll on the
past present and future of battlefield
in October 2014 publisher EA confirmed a
new entry in the battlefield series will
ship in 2016 chief financial officer
Blake Jorgensen said a plan to have a
new shooter yearly and would follow up
star wars battlefront with a battlefield
he a also previously said that Mass
Effect Andromeda titanfall two and
battlefield 5 would be out during fiscal
year twenty 17 which runs from april
first 2016 through to march 31st 2017 a
tease of title 2 has been released an EA
plans to reveal it on jun 12 so will the
promise of free DLC be enough to get you
back on the battlefield let us know in
the comments section below or find me on
Twitter at irregular Dave and for new
battlefield news stay tuned to gamespot
com